solitare is one of the most popular
computer games of all time and we went
to find the guy who created yes may I
help you are you the person that wrote
solitaire for Microsoft yes but that was
a long time ago we gotta talk to McMinn
great thank you
[Music]
all right this is what I'm West Cherry
and I wrote Windows solitaire I wrote
the game in 1988 as an intern
internships at Microsoft were really
all-encompassing things but I suppose
within there and a few little hours of
my free time for those who need a
refresher volunteer was played on the
computer using a mouse cards are pulled
from the deck in an effort to stack
cards in order by suit and if you won
you got an awesome display of cards
cascading towards eyo I came up with the
idea to write solitaire for Windows out
of boredom really there wasn't many
games right at the time so we had to
make up in the mid to late 90s was just
when people started really getting
computers in their home Microsoft
officially said that solitaire was there
to teach people how to use them out but
in reality it was just really just
something to have fun with before they
were released windows of course Bill
Gates got a shot at it
his biggest complaint was that solitaire
was too hard to win and once people
figured out the mouse it became a
favorite pastime the number of hours
wasted on solitaire is really countless
I can say that right after solitaire was
released in 1990 there was a world
recession so many people were playing in
the workplace that West came up with
what he called the boss key press the
special key and a spreadsheet was come
up that made it look like you were doing
real work but Microsoft made me take it
out considering the game has been around
for decades
let them need a ton of money I was not
aid not a single game at one time I said
if I only got a penny for copy I would
be
very rich so far only 14 people made
good on that I'm still waiting for the
rest of you well you heard the man
do you still work with computers I work
with an apple now apples actually Verena
cidery uh what there's something behind
you let's run